to start with anyone that would finance
a cat or a dog definitely a cat is an
idiot I mean honestly if you finance a
freakin pet you're a straight-up fool I
mean I will be in business forever as
long as there are people that's dumb out
there it's unbelievable
this is stupid on steroids right here so
let me get this straight lady you walk
in to buy a dog you spent you buy a
different you impulse and buy a
different dog spend more than twenty
four hundred dollars but didn't have
twenty four hundred dollars so you
agreed to finance that you thought and
oh guess what this person who's not real
good at details and impulses a lot of
things didn't read the paperwork I'm
shocked and it's someone else's fault
that you got ripped off no you got
ripped off lady because you're stupid
that's why you got ripped off that was
straight-up dumb right there
unbelievable I mean how do you lease a
dog and not know it
this is beyond bizarre the the stupid
human tricks and and here's the thing -
let me tell you if you're a pet store
and you're putting this stuff out there
you ought to be ashamed of yourself I
mean you shame yourself finance a dog
financed by cat unbelievable now listen
if you don't have the money to buy the
dog you don't have the money to support
the dog and there's a lot of sweet
little puppies of the pound that needs
some help and by the way oh and then you
get the dog home and it's a puppy Israel
a Golden Retriever puppy is rambunctious
well what the crap did you think it was
going to be did you think it was going
to lay in the corner and purr this is a
large dog did you think it was a large
dog that's going to be rambunctious
what did you think you were getting lady
this is the problem we're dealing with
four-year-olds walking around in adult
bodies making these decisions and
blaming everyone else for their
stupidity now I've done lots of stupid
things and if you've done stupid things
I'm on your team I'm not going to be mad
at you forever they've helped me I was
stupid I'll help you if you were stupid
I've been stupid I'm not mad about
stupid
I'm not saying someone's stupid and I've
not been stupid I have been stupid get
the idea here but this is stupid you
financed a dog a $2,400 dog I bought
lots of cars cheaper than that chick and
then you didn't even read the stuff to
realize you weren't really financing it
you're really leasing it which is
actually another method of financing it
but 70% interest I mean really
and then people wonder why I'm going to
be in business forever I mean me and
Jenny Craig we got a lot of work to do
there's a lot of said you know we just
got a lot of work to do there's a it's
just never-ending a $1700 Bengal cat
really unbelievable I grew up in a
different generation cats came and went
pretty regularly I'll just tell you like
Jeff Foxworthy talks about my I got a
cat one I tore my momma's curtains in
the next day that cat ran away
it's what my dad said he still had a dog
one time two doves oh my dad's stuff and
the next day that's all ran away that's
how I grew up you guys I don't get this
$2,400 financing a dog now I love golden
retrievers I've got one it may be one of
the best dogs on the planet
I'm not financing the freakin dog you
guys I mean this is dumb Oh eleris
absolutely hilarious just i I will never
be out of work people I will never be
able to work we are here to serve you
this is the Dave Ramsey show hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
[Music]